April 1st will be a major test for
millions of Americans already stressed
by the economic impact of koban 19 rents
will be the first in a series of April
bills that many American households
won't be able to pay this comes at a
time when according to the Federal
Reserve only 4 out of 10 Americans would
be able to cover a $400 of emergency
expense without borrowing money or
running out more credit card debt while
relief is on the way for many thanks to
the 2.2 trillion dollar relief fund
signed on March 27th most people won't
see that cash for at least three weeks
so what are some things you can do if
you're low on funds and can't pay all
your bills right now first identify all
your recurring and necessary expenses
like housing and utilities personal
finance expert Stephanie O'Connell says
if they can be covered with cash you do
have use those savings take financial
inventory of those necessary expenses
that happen every month like your
housing costs your utility costs your
grocery costs insurance things that are
true needs and if you have the savings
to finance that that's what your savings
is for you save that money to spend it
in a moment of need and keeping a roof
over your head or keeping food on your
table is a moment of need that said I
think the clearer you can get about your
actual costs the better off you're gonna
be because then once you know how much
it costs you to live each month you can
look at the balance in your savings
account and say based on how much it
costs me to live on a bare-bones budget
basis this is how much is my savings
account and this is how many months this
will last me at this rate second
get in touch with every company or
person you owe money to depending on
where you live and who you're dealing
with you may be able to put some
payments on hold or some may have
already been frozen for the time being
credit card companies and loan providers
are often willing to work with customers
to implement a payment
and forget especially if you have good
credit some are even offering financial
hardship plans in light of the
coronavirus but never assume these plans
will be implemented automatically be
sure to call and ask before you stop
painting finally if you've exhausted
every option and are still in a tough
spot
Stephanie McConnell says you may have to
consider what trade-offs you're willing
to make if you're at the point where
you've checked with every service
provider you've checked with your
lenders you've checked all of the local
federal and state policies then you
might still be in a position of having
to decide ok what does get paid and and
and what bills don't and in that regard
I think something a tool like a credit
card can be really really valuable
because even though credit cards tend to
come with pretty high interest rates the
fact is a credit card is gonna get you
food on the table and if it comes
between having groceries and not you're
gonna pick groceries according to
economists at the Federal Reserve Bank
of st. Louis the köppen 19 outbreak
could potentially wipe out 47 million
jobs in the United States next quarter
this would push unemployment to 32 point
one percent well above the 24.9% it was
during the worst of the Great Depression
in the 1930s
you